[Musique]
e
bon
on appelle les nouvelles jantes et
[Musique]
oh
et
non c'est très bien
la partie
temps
alors du coup on va commencer donc quand
même je vous ai dit je m'appelle fille
annie et je suis donc infirmières
d'accueil chez wind and safe
et puis on va faire ensemble votre
premier rendez vous vous allez me
raconter ce qui vous amène est-ce qu'on
peut essayer de faire un résumé et de
façon chronologique je sais que c'est un
exercice qui est pas facile mais ça va
me permettre au moins moi de bien
comprendre la situation et qu'on puisse
vous aider au mieux après
mon père était violent
il y avait une violence une sorte de
rage colère ou d'incompréhension
intérieur qui s'exprimait par les
colères des violences alors moi déjà
j'étais victime très tôt à l'âge de
trois semaines des violences de mon père
qui savait pas
comment maîtriser mes pleurs et ma mère
m'a raconté qu'il n'avait mordu la joue
jusque
tellement fort que j'ai eu un hématome
pendant trois jours donné j'avais trois
semaines c'est fou quoi donc sa place à
planques le personnage déjà
et donc à partir de là
disons que par rapport à certains
comportements dans mon intimité je suis
et surtout le ce que j'ai subi après
comme attouchements agression viol
je pense que c'était lié à
à des attouchements de la part
de la mousserie père et ma soeur m'a
confirmé et d'après les souvenirs que
vous avez vous aviez quel âge à peu près
quatre ans d'accord donc c'était donc
mais peut-être argent aussi d'accord
ma soeur elle a le souvenir moi j'ai le
souvenir qu avait quelque chose de pas
net j'ai le souvenir qu'on venait dans
son nid qu'il était nu et que son sexe
était en érection et après black out
est donc aujourd'hui c'est ce qui vous
handicape en tout cas c'est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils vont un petit peu et des
bâtons dans les roues donc après toute
ma vie ah oui alors c'est l'ont fait
certaines souvent je suis traitée de
folle je suis traiter d'affabulatrice de
menteuse
c'est une énorme souffrance
j'entends bien mais voilà rassurés vont
ici on vous croit
quand les victimes arrivent chez nous
elles sont anéantis et elle recherche
dans l'association une force qu'elles
ont perdu à cause de leur parcours le
premier rendez vous ça va être le moment
où on va vraiment créer le lien de
confiance avec la victime
[Musique]
on va essayer de faire une vision un peu
à 360 sur la situation donc le fait
qu'on soit infirmières justement on va
pouvoir percevoir un petit peu cette
globalité de la situation on va avoir un
oeil un peu psychologique un oeil un
petit peu médical aussi puis il a porté
cette écoute bienveillante
une fois qu'on a terminé ce premier
rendez vous où va réunir plusieurs corps
de métiers différents de l'association
avec lesquels on va pouvoir discuter de
la situation convient d'avoir et ça va
permettre aussi de transmettre la
situation par exemple à ma collègue qui
pourrait l'avoir en rendez vous le
lendemain ce qui va bien sûr éviter à la
victime de raconter une nouvelle fois
son histoire
donc leur numéro 3616 elle vient parce
que la cheville un cervidé violence elle
est donc sa soeur ont des flèches donc
leur se voit aux alentours de 4 ans dont
le lit de ses parents avec son père et
sa soeur puis black out complet à partir
de ce moment là il y avait plein
violence dans sa vie tout le temps elle
parle de viols d'agressions de
harcèlement moral au travail depuis neuf
ans de difficultés dans ses relations
amicales notamment avec des femmes et
dit qu'elle a subi beaucoup de violence
il est proposé de la revoir
j'aimerais faire un état des lieux en
fait général sur elle avant de le
remonter m6 j'ai lu sonia 31 90
sonia c'est un concept du coup
violent dans l'enfance par ses trois
frères
elle vient d'entendre que sa plainte
puisse un jour être classé jeu c'est
quand même plus tard prendre conscience
de ça ce que ça peut arriver ça fait
quand même trente ans voilà
quand même on sait jamais quoi tu as
tout dit clairement que s'il s'est
classé à salade et rêveur mais bon on
avance alors moi j'ai eu juste 34 85
myriam elle veut divorcer monsieur veut
pas en ce moment c'est plutôt calme au
niveau des violences ça s'est apaisé
parce qu'elle évite surtout les conflits
donc du coup orientation avocat le 12
mai à l'air plutôt décidé donc je pense
que ça ira ça ira pour elle il faudra
juste là l'orienter vers l'aide
juridictionnelle casse au vu des revenus
je pense qu'elle aura pas une aide
totale alors à punaises partiel alors
les à 32 65
ça va pas
et on s'est aperçu qu'elle ait entente
de cinq semaines
pour elle c'est très difficile parce
qu'elles pensent pas pouvoir accueillir
l'enfant comme il se doit dans de bonnes
conditions pour l'instant et donc elle
va parler
d'interruption moi j'ai eu la sage femme
elle a pris la décision a pris la
décision même parce que disputait là
c'était hors de question et puis on a
fait les cons ensemble et comme elle a
su que c'était tout petit petit petit
c'est ce qui a un peu fait changer
est-ce qu'il a beaucoup rassuré c'est
savoir qu'on avait d'autres femmes où
elle qu'un interrompre et comme elles dé
grossesse et qu'elle était pas tout seul
acte du directeur à ces saccages des
gravats là c'est parce que tout ça
n'était pas ça à faire ma propre idée là
et qu'il ya d'être fade enfin bref donc
voilà je recommande
[Musique]
en fait on a réfléchi à travers les
femmes et leur difficulté à pouvoir
avancer on avait constaté qu'elle en
était beaucoup orienté réorienter une
fois qu'elle voyait une assistante
sociale on l'orienté vers un juriste par
exemple et c'était très très difficile
pour elle est souvent reproché à ces
victimes de ne pas faire ce qu'on leur
conseiller
en fait l'idée du centre ici c'était de
cultiver de travailler ensemble quelle
que soit la profession que l'on exerce
et sa formation initiale et on se disait
notre enjeu c'est d'y installer aussi
cette notion du partage de l'information
qu'ils allaient pouvoir effectivement
être principalement au bénéfice de la
victime
j'arrive dans la journée a finalement
prendre plus de recul ce qui fait que le
soir j'arrive à me
vous conte vandalisés a essayé de
m'endormir paisiblement et le matin je
me réveille et
c'est débordant
c'est triste angoisses et
l'abattage
et toute la journée
situation aujourd'hui
la plupart du temps les victimes qui
arrivent ici sont dans un état de
souffrance psychologique immense dans un
état d'épuisement vraiment immense il ya
beaucoup de femmes qui arrive avec des
idées profondément noire des idées
suicidaires forte et même des scénarios
suicidaire déjà bien bien bien avancé et
nous on est là pour essayer de calmer un
petit peu leur état interne parce que
c'est un volcan un volcan de désespoir
en fait j'ai l'impression de
pratiquer en fait quand j'étais enfant
je n'étais pas considérer que ce que je
disais n'avaient pas de poids quoi donc
c'est vrai que bâle ont fait revivre sa
chance hein
il actualise les interrupteurs ça c'est
sûr du coup ses blessures là on peut
essayer de l'est contre balancer en
en étant en relation avec des personnes
qui vont vous faire ressentir tout l'
inverse donc qui sont les personnes
autour de vous qui vous trouve
intéressante qui vous trouvent
aimable qui qui qui vous aiment qui qui
vous apprécie pour ce que vous êtes et
caetera et caetera et on se tourne vers
ses percées ce que je sais ce que j'ai
fait en fait là pour la semaine dernière
pour
travailler là dessus que j'ai bien senti
j'avais besoin d'un soutien à voir ce
qu'ils me ce qui me désole aussi se
trouver en moi même ça forcément besoin
de l'extérieur mon foie
bienveillance bienveillance envers soi
même et ne soyez pas désolé des
réactions que vous avez et que vous
arrivez pas surtout à contrôler
ouais ouais
facile à devenir
je le note mais bonjour c'est ce que
jean frère
[Rires]
[Musique]
on est là pour essayer de leur montrer
que on va pas réussir à résoudre leur
problématique de manière miraculeuse qui
va falloir du temps mais qu'on sait
faire
donc si elle accepte de nous donner du
temps et nous donner un peu de confiance
peut-être qu'on arrivera à gagner le
pari ensemble
je laisse pas cette ancienne agente
[Musique]
il veut dans le premier monde situé dans
l'est pas
pitbull et
propose je pense si vous étiez pas moi
je chante du pardon je suis la juriste
madame la de ce que vous dites c'est
qu'il ya une urgence que vous pouvez pas
rester à la maison c'est ça avec votre
petite fille hier je reste et tout
autour d'une barre chaque fois à l'aube
du jour
vous n'êtes jamais en sécurité avec
votre fille dans la maison mais là c'est
plus possible donc parce que chaque fois
ils vont prendre
on n'a pas vocation normalement à gérer
des situations d'urgence après c'est
quand même assez fréquent qu'on ait des
personnes qui viennent sur place en
disant voilà j'ai besoin de partir tout
de suite où je ne peux pas rentrer chez
moi où j'ai été violentée qu'est ce que
je fais
et bien sûr là on les prend en urgence
et puis on leur apporte les premières
réponses donc là pour que vous puissiez
vous mettre en protection à coller
qu'elle vous donne les coordonnées pour
aller au commissariat d'accord donc pour
faire une main courante si vous voulez
partir ce soir
tout à l'heure du leur prix le passeport
de mon petit fils oui c'est pas partir
chez son frère chez sa soeur je vous
déposez un plein de ce retour oui mais
sauf que monsieur il dit des choses qui
sont pas la loi voyez il dit des choses
pour vous faire peur vous menacent donc
justement pour pas qu'il dise ça vous
avez juste dire au commissariat voilà je
suis fatiguée par tout ce qui se passe
il ya des violences dans mon couple ça
se passe pas bien et vous dites bien je
pars pas définitivement je m'enfuis pas
du pays je ne triche pas ma fille ni des
ne sont pas pas définitivement pour que
si monsieur ensuite il dit c'est
interdit de faire ça vous glissez dire
non je suis juste parti quelques jours
vous avez le droit de partir quelques
jours pour souffler
pour nous la plus grosse difficulté
finalement ces deux
on presque de déjouer les stratégies de
l'auteur des violences est presque un
lavage de cerveau qu elles ont subit
donc il faut du temps pour que nous on
arrive à reposer une réalité qui est
différente de ce qu'elles vivent au
quotidien et elle passe quelques heures
chez nous elle passe la majorité du
temps à leur domicile avec l'auteur des
violences comme celles des violences
intrafamiliales donc voilà ça peut
prendre plusieurs plusieurs rendez-vous
avant qu' elle soit confortée dans ok
j'ai des droits je peux faire des choses
bon qu'à au lit
asseyez-vous tranquillement oui on est
tout content de vous recevoir toutes les
deux hommes étaient
donc on s'est vus pour la première fois
il ya un an et demi un oui c'était à la
suite d'un accouchement traumatique qui
s'était mal passé tout à fait dans vous
antécédents il ya des violences
sexuelles de 10 à 14 ans 1 donc tout ça
ça peut générer
des faits un psycho trop bas qui peut
être réactivé à l'occasion d'un
événement gynéco je pense que depuis on
l'accouchement j'ai développé mon père
qui est au delà d'une peur qui fait que
je ne peux plus avoir de relations
sexuelles ce que je suis le chrome
attiser la l1 c'est ce que j'ai eu oui
venez pas ressortis
tout de suite vous l'avez dans ma tête
tous les jours tout le temps et ça
faisait partie de moi je jouais dit là
il est ressorti depuis une petite année
de façon vraiment très très prégnante il
n'y a pas eu d'action juridiquement de
dénonciation de vos auteurs de voilà de
reconnaissance pour vous de votre statut
de victime là il ya le chrono qui tourne
on va dire parce que avec les voilà on
sait que au niveau de la prescription
vous arrivez un sens à timing c'est faux
voilà moins d'un an donc il faut cirer
il faut y réfléchir
soit vous avez envie d'aller déposer
plainte dans un commissariat parce que
c'est important de passer les portes du
commissariat de d'être face à un
policier ou un gendarme un de voir
quelqu'un en face à face qui note est
d'avoir une audition qui peut être
longue j'ai eu des situations de femmes
qui m'ont dit on a eu deux trois deux
trois quatre heures d'audition parce que
ça prend du temps de raconter tout ça
sinon si vous voulez pas avoir deux face
à face parce que c'est trop difficile
dans un premier temps on peut ensemble
déjà c'est écrire écrire au procureur
préparer voilà une lettre
détaillée mais pas trop simplement il
faut savoir que derrière il va demander
à ce que vous soyez entendu on n'est pas
là pour leur donner ce que nous on
imagine le mieux pour elle mais on leur
donne l'ensemble les solutions
juridiques qui peuvent être apportées ça
permet vraiment qu'elle puisse
finalement réfléchir à l'ensemble de
leurs options est de savoir aussi pesé
le pour et le contre
typiquement dans les dépôts de plainte
il faut savoir qu'il ya un risque
d'échec de la procédure et ça c'est
notre rôle de les informer parce que
c'est une double violence quand la
justice donne pas raison à ce que la
victime attend moi ce que j'essaye de
travailler avec elle c'est vous fait des
démarches non pas pour une condamnation
derrière mais pour vous pour que vous
soyez reconnu pour que vous ayez parler
qu'une trace de ce qui s'est passé en
fait comme il ya eu aussi ces derniers
temps un baume à médiatique ben oui je
vois sur l'inceste oui c'est vrai que
forcément pour quelqu'un qui l'a vécu ça
fait forcément un coût et donc je me
suis dit qu'un embryon tu n'as pas le
droit de rien faire pour toi je fais pas
pour lui
voilà c'est fini tout ça mais je le fais
pour moi moi je pense que c'est quand
même important que vous ayez une
psychologue qui connaissent la question
des violences sexuelles et la justice
oui pendant cette période la presse que
nous on va on va travailler vraiment sur
le concret de la procédure oui mais vous
aurez certainement besoin de parler de
ce que ça fait ressortir des angoisses
etc on peut en parler à toutes les deux
bien tuer elle aura une autre approche
complémentaire d'accord
du coup je me suis dit qui peut faire ça
et la reine de la section grenat et donc
on a dit c'est louise
à louise pense au cercle de parole est
maintenant haut-parleurs s'est brouillé
avec joueurs approche
coucou louise sa série de suggestions
intéressant on n'ya pas pensé est ce que
c'est une formule qui lui conviendra
d'attendre jusque là si on a protégé
entre mettez le congé de la place ce
soir là ok je vais regarder son planning
et je vais la jouer il ajouté allez
[Musique]
je m'appelle luis j'ai 23 ans et je suis
étudiante en théâtre
[Musique]
j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle de l'amnésie
traumatique qui est que
le trauma que j'ai subie mon cerveau l'a
mis quelque part très loin
et à un jour où il ya eu un choc qui a
fait remonter tous les souvenirs à la
surface
et donc des images
sans arrêt des traumas que j'avais subi
des violences sexuelles que j'avais subi
c'était c'était non stop sans fin
[Musique]
j'ai connu maif par le biais d'un ami
qui s'était renseigné pour moi j'ai eu
super peur au début et puis en fait ça
oui ça m'a soulagé ça m'a vraiment
allégé mais vraiment allégé parce que
j'étais plus tout seul et dès qu'on est
au contact de plusieurs femmes qui qui
sont différentes et qui en plus se sont
dans des corps de métiers différents et
qu'ils me prennent en charge comme ça
ben ça m'a sauvé la vie
disons en fuite
dans un monde idéal j'aimerais vraiment
être capable d'être en colère de dire
que ça c'est en tout cas pour moi c'est
vraiment beaucoup de
beaucoup d'énervement beaucoup de colère
contre plein de choses que je peux pas
maîtriser quoi il ya ça et puis même
n'ont pas la possibilité d'être instable
d'être moins forte
ça ça me met en colère j'ai l'impression
qu'on n'a pas le droit enfin jeu
que la société veut pas qu'on ait le
droit et que quand on tourne était petit
bard n'avez pas le droit de façon dont
on fait les comptes femme notre gueule
et voilà comme si à un moment donné il
fallait qu'on la rêve d'être en colère
comme si c'était ça un mot des fautes on
dit c'est bon c'est fini on est passé à
autre chose est un peu en mode bat
peut-être que je serai toujours en
colère est ce que c'est si grave que ça
afin que c'est si grave ne pas pardonner
parce que du coup ça fait de moi une
mauvaise victime qui est juste encore en
colère et que du coup je n'ai pas avancé
sur le bon chemin de la victime fin
moi j'ai constamment peur de déranger
déranger parce que j'ai besoin dead mais
en même temps si je demande de l'être
dire que j'emporte quelqu'un d'autre
dans mes histoires donc est-ce que je
vais pas blessé sept personnes mans en
l'emportant dans mes histoires je faire
découvrir un peu la douleur que moi je
vis
forcément ça va les marquer et après
baroin va me le reprocher à moi il
montre que j'en ai marre
les victimes qu'on voit dans nos bureaux
elles sont souvent avec des des
problématiques très très similaires ce
qui fait que ça m'a aussi poussé à
ouvrir des secteurs parole le fait quand
tu es enfant d'intégrer des choses comme
ça aujourd'hui je me rends compte à quel
point c'est c'est choquant et à quel
point
ça gâche la vie dans les relations que
j'ai envie de dire presque avec tout le
monde quoi mon but c'est de donner de
moyens et de la puissance aux victimes
la puissance de témoigner la puissance
de pouvoir exprimer ce qu'elles ont vécu
de pouvoir ou pas il y en a qui n'ont
pas envie mais en tout cas fin de leur
redonner leur confiance en elles de leur
redonner les armes qu'elle en avait
perdu quand il ya eu les violences qu'on
a vécu tout ça les repères sont pas
construits avec les bons repères non
plus ni par rapport à notre corps est à
nouveau ressenti ni aussi à
l'interaction avec les autres et les
autres l'autre celui l'homme qui
pourrait devenir lamoureux le père des
enfants de nos enfants que tu parlais
tout à l'heure le fait d'être parent
donne et ces notions cij a alors moi
j'ai l'impression que j'avais souhaité
tout un truc pour pardonner ça je me
suis aperçu qu'en fait c'était une
illusion et que j'arrive pas à pardonner
et je veux pas en fait je vais pas
accepter on a la légitimité de ne pas
pardonner on a la légitimité d'être en
colère on a la légitimité aussi d'avoir
peur peut-être on a le droit aussi deux
heures bal a en fait avec les hommes par
exemple c'est difficile et que ce ne
soit pas pour autant un symptôme
je sais que moi j'ai
les hommes c'est une
des créatures
très très spécial pour moi j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait
d'indexer un homme c'est plus difficile
ça peut être un voisin ça peut être un
collègue cela peut être
[Musique]
des connaissances le contact va super
bien passé ça va bien se passer mais
pour autant dès que c'est un homme c'est
différent c'est super étrange elles
attendent tout ce qui est un moment
magique où le trauma y sera oublié
où il y aura plus de symptômes et il y
aura un espèce de moments comme ça de
révélation que ça qui est attendu
partout les victimes si j'ai en fait ce
moment magique il ya déjà en train
d'être actée en fait partir du moment où
une victime elle frappe à la porte d'un
psychologue et d'un thérapeute ou d'un
médecin ou je sais pas quoi et qu'elle
veut parler de ça et qu'elle est dans
une demande de que ça se soit pris en
charge elle est déjà dans quelque chose
de réparateur pour elle-même quoi
comment vous vous sentez comment vous
appréhendez le retour dans l'autre monde
moi ça va je crois je suis plus calme
que en arrivant
j'aime j'aime bien ça fait du bien de
parler de faire parler son jeu peut-on
parler d'ailleurs mais ça fait du bien
d'entendre parler de ça en fait voilà je
suis content nous merci
[Musique]
où
il on
[Musique]
oui bonjour lisa c'est marie do maine
safe c'est juste pour qu'on re planifier
un rendez vous parce que comme tu avais
pas trop la forme
je peux proposer si tu est dispo 11h30
ce vendredi ça te va ça quand il était
très énervé il a déjà traité à l'autre
oui santé qu'une grosse conne à laquelle
m
des menaces vous avez eu peur
que vous êtes a fait le plein pas dessus
alors la deuxième place c'est pour mon
doigt cassé voilà la troisième femme
c'est pour le harcèlement
quelle partie
[Musique]
alors toi sur le dos la tête ici
dimanche je devais trop mal je plains
plus en mouvement
est-ce que tu avais déjà été j'en ostéo
de cuite avait avalé par les deux des
problématiques de violence que j allais
tous un nom
prend une grande inspiration
mes sous
[Musique]
suite à toutes les agressions que j'ai
vécu g j'ai essayé de reprendre une vie
normale en fait sauf que j'ai commencé à
avoir des cauchemars des flashs des
angoisses j'ai eu ensuite des troubles
de la sexualité et j'avais beaucoup de
perturbations en fait dans mon couple
c'était devenu vital en fait que je
prenne mon passé en mains et que
j'arrête de mettre un couvercle sur sur
ce qui me faisait peur
depuis la dernière séance ça va certes
beaucoup mieux mais en terme de
de croyance c'est une catastrophe dans
le sens où
je suis tout le temps à me dire des de
plus en plus on fait ça c'est pas
vraiment arriver même c'est une partira
finale qui me dit non tu as vraiment
j'ai eu des culs des violences si une
autre partie qui n'était toujours là à
me dire oui mais oui mais
donc tu sais dis toi que c'est une façon
pour ton cerveau de pouvoir s'apaiser
que d'essayer de faire comme si ça
n'était pas arrivé parce que si c'est
arrivé le danger il est tellement énorme
que mais du coup c'est un énorme paquet
tu vois intégré et ton cerveau il n'y
arrive pas tout ça donc son moyen de
protection c'est de flouter un peu tout
ça est de se dire bon bah finalement en
tête que je sais pas etc etc
on va reprendre ce souvenir et faire en
sorte que tu es plus à douter de ce qui
s'est passé donc je
vais te demander de fermer les yeux si
c'est inconfortable pour toi de fermer
les yeux tu hésites pas tu les rennais
donc je vais être demandé tout
simplement de laisser revenir ce qu'il
t'a paraît et quand tu sens que ça
commence à bouger à l'intérieur de toi
tu peux voir les yeux une commencent
leur traitement
je me suis anti faisait presque nous un
appartement
quand je suis rentré dedans ça me
revient
il y avait un vieux matelas par terre
et
et avec la paille sur le sol il y avait
il y avait plein de choses dégueulasses
partout mais il y avait particulièrement
de la paille et le matelas était très
attaché
après je sais plus qui s'est passé
qu'est ce que ça te fait ressentir la
main
j'ai ressenti
[Musique]
des zones de tremblements quand je me
suis rappelé de l'as lattes et
psycho traumatologie on part du principe
qu'une victime elle porte son trauma
d'abord dans son corps c'est une
personne qui vit constamment sentiment
d'insécurité avec l'idée qu'à n'importe
quel moment n'importe qui peut
l'agresser parce que l'événement il a
été brutal il a été soudain il a été
inattendue il a tout fait exploser en
vol le corse est bloqué dans du passé il
faut qu'on lui prouve à ce corps qu'on
est plus dans cette époque là et donc on
va travailler bribe par bribe élément
par élément et on reconstitue le
souvenir pour que la personne puisse
avoir un début un milieu une fin sur ce
qui s'est passé on va repartir sur
l'image
on le temps de la laisser revenir et
quand elle apparaît dis moi comment elle
tu apparais main
je sens que le
le souvenir est en train de vivre en
paix
de ce moment là alors écoute moi ok tu
peux me regarder
on va le laisser venir pour pouvoir
l'intégrer donc tu peux
expliquer à ton cerveau qui peut le
laisser revenir on va le prendre en
charge ptac est deux
je sais plus exactement comment est-ce
que c'est arrivé mais je crois que
c'était à peu près à la fin et
je me suis qu'il y avait ses bras qui me
touchait au niveau du dos et sam était
très très mal
je sais que j'ai dis donc je voulais pas
quand tu lui le raconte la maintenir
qu'est ce qui se passe en toi ça me fait
un peu comme des chocs électriques qui
reviennent j'étais sorte de de frissons
tremblements
je te demande de te concentrer là dessus
laisse venir
leenders et les acronymes de eyes
movement dit sensibilisation resizing
pour la faire courte on retraite un
souvenir et on désensibilise via le
mouvement oculaire
quand on fait dieu le balayage visuel on
va activer le cerveau de manière
bilatérale
ce qu'on cherche à faire en emdr c'est
permettre la personne d'avoir accès à un
maximum d'informations sans que ce soit
trop douloureux pour elle sans que cela
fasse sortir de sa fenêtre de tolérance
mais qu'elles puissent du coup continuer
à encoder normalement le souvenir qui
n'a jamais été encodée jusqu alors
n'est-ce pas tout
[Musique]
j'ai envie de me tue fait patte effondré
on est toutes les deux
continuent
c'est du passé on laisse intégré hockey
aujourd'hui je suis en sécurité avec moi
je suis parent
ma sculpture humain
maintenant je sais que c'est
aussi une thérapie tu es très difficile
elle est très intense et ça demande
beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie mais ça me
permet de prendre beaucoup de recul par
rapport à ce qui m'est arrivé
j'ai
une amélioration dans la façon de gérer
mes angoisses j'ai plus de cauchemars et
puis je vis beaucoup plus sereinement et
ça permet de reprendre confiance en soi
de se dire bon certes c'est difficile
mais maintenant j'en suis à la et je
sais que je peux continuer
[Musique]
vous allez bien à parler ça peut aller
en fait la raf a sûrement il yal'idée
nous fait don wake on lan ma vie c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes suivi
depuis déjà un petit moment à
l'association et au fur et à mesure des
rendez-vous tna l'impression que votre
état se dégrade de prison plus en tout
cas par moments oui et c'est ça qui nous
fait donc le dernier
c'est quelque chose qui dira que 12 que
j'allais là haut
on touchait bourbaki pau non désolé mais
être pas dû voir
non c'est la dernière chose à laquelle
je m'attendais une fusée au cri de la
sport les cellules
dimanche encore dernier j'ai pas encore
2e
il rompu
oui en tout cas on entend bien la
souffrance dans laquelle vous êtes
aujourd'hui et c'est tout à fait normal
face à ce que vous vivez mais on est un
petit peu démuni face à tout ce qui vous
arrive du lycée là donc c'est normal
votre et high heels année c'est ce qui
nécessiterait peut-être une
hospitalisation au moins le temps que
vous vous puissiez vous retrouver que
vous puissiez avoir les landes et r
oui mais vous serez peut-être en
sécurité par rapport à vous même
je pense qu'elle a compris qu'en notre
inquiétude
vous pouvez
pas qu'elle se fasse hospitalisés et je
sais déjà elle un suivi psychiatrique
avec un psychiatre la voix de versements
régulière j'espère que cette dame elle
va finir par prendre conscience que ce
qu'on fait c'est pour son bien et que
c'est pas c'est pas parce qu'on veut
plus la recevoir c'est parce qu'on ne
peut plus à l'heure actuelle il faut
vraiment qu'elle puisse prendre
conscience de la gravité des faits à la
fois pour elle et ses enfants et qu'elle
puisse surtout prendre soin d'elle je
pense que c'est le moment pour elle
c'est pas trop dur de faire ça c'est si
c'est humainement c'est très difficile
après il faut il faut pas perdre
il faut pas perdre de vue l'objectif
c'est vraiment pour elle qu'on fait ça
même si sur le moment ça peut être perçu
al'inverse en dire elle peut se sentir
abandonnés puisque finalement on est
obligé un peu de mettre un terme
temporairement à sa prise en charge
mais par la suite je sais que cette dame
une fois qu'elle aura réussi elle
reviendra nous voir et nous dira que
c'était la bonne solution
[Musique]
je vous propose de vous installer la
bon je suis beau but mais là je
suis parti de la maison ça fait un an
que je suis indépendante on peut dire
que j'ai fait mon choix tout seul le
mari nage c'est un temps très très fort
pour une femme qui a vu sa situation
avancée et qui a envie de partager avec
une autre femme dans une très grosse
difficulté à ce moment-là de moi
j'appelle ça des trucs et astuces donc
voyager professionnels se mettent à ce
moment là on te pose donc voilà je
commence à peine de
vivre ma propre vie et ce n'est pas
facile parce que en j'ai l'impression de
recommencer
pratiquement recommencer ma vie une fois
j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit il faut que
je me considère comme un bébé d'un an
c'est à dire voilà je commence à refaire
mes premiers pas et je commence à vivre
de nouveau
c'est mme bah
oui ça me parle sauf que moi je suis pas
encore prête à annoncer tous ces mâles
femmes je ne suis pas du tout prêt parce
que parce qu'effectivement je suis pas
un seul j'ai quand même eu 3000 trois
fils c'est très difficile voilà et je
sais que pour l'an dernier ce sera
vraiment hyper compliqué et c'est ça qui
m'a freiné beaucoup russie je me suis
dit avec les enfants où je vais partir
on vivre sous un pont comme ça j'ai tenu
plusieurs années et il y avait une
grande crise j'ai eu trop peur pour ma
vie il fallait que je trouve une
solution je suis partie un jour c'était
une soirée terrible mais je suis parti
comme quand même grâce au soutien de mes
enfants
alors justement ces soutiens de ces
enfants c'est quelque chose qui est
particulier parce que vous l'avez pas
ils vous disent quoi vos enfants quand
vous leur parlez de la séparation avec
leur père maintenant qu'ils comprennent
pas enfants qu'ils veulent rester dans
son lit leurs amis de tous
les enfants ils ressentent je pense que
ce genre de d'ambivalence parce qu'ils
ne savent pas de quel côté se déplacer
pendant les crises c'est sûr qu'ils sont
deux côtés de la victime des crises mais
après il commence à se poser des
questions et commençait presque à sentir
un genre d'inquiétude pour ses pour ce
papa qui qu'il ya une victime de
lui-même
après je pense que avec le recul il
arrivera à relativiser en lisant
effectivement elle a bien fait parce que
j'ose espérer qu'ils vont pouvoir faire
ce chemin là mais
oui après ce que vous allez
financièrement aussi c'est vrai que on
se pose on se pose des questions même si
je sais que on peut y arriver mais je
suis parti tout seul c'était terrible
parce que je n'ai je n'ai pas eu les
moyens de louer un appartement plus
grand donc je ne pouvais pas embarquer
ma fille c'était très difficile je
dormais très mal mais comme mon mari
parce qu'il a toujours mon numéro de
téléphone donc qu'ils m'appellent mais
après je me suis rendu compte que je
pouvais
fermer le téléphone ne plus entendre ces
mots terribles qui est que j'ai entendu
pendant des années
je me dis ah je ne suis pas obligé de
l'écouter jusqu'à 1h dans la nuit désert
3h dans la nuit je perds à coucher
quel soulagement
je rajouterais une autre chose il faut
que vous preniez conscience que pour moi
une victime c'est quelqu'un qui rentre
la première fois au commissariat c'est à
dire c'est pas un monde où on est
habitués à rentrer en fait ce qu'elles
vont vous déclarez vous paraîtra pas
très clair pascal est stressé il faut
vraiment que vous considérez que les
victimes avaient complètement terrorisé
de deux fois revenir vous voir à un
moment il faut que nous six policiers en
soit capable de regarder nos nos travers
en face et nos failles et dire alors je
vous le dis pas pour vous jeudi pour moi
parce que vous venez d'arriver donc vous
tomberez pas dans ses travers là
on a pendant très longtemps mis en doute
la parole des victimes quand la victime
à la rive ne voulait pas dénoncer en
disant oui mais la libye que depuis dix
ans mais là elle a peur elle dit qu'il
l'a giflée à la pas de traces à la pas
au top la victime on verra tout à
l'heure elle arrive elle veut des
garanties que vous la croyez
l'enquêté dira ce que j'entends de
fabienne aujourd'hui qui a une parole
sans tabou pour moi c'est très important
parce que vous êtes une autorité et nous
on est à des acteurs de cet écosystème
et je trouve que cette franchise qu'elle
a de vous dire les choses elle nous
apprend aussi beaucoup je vous encourage
à venir demander des stages chez nous
vous allez voir l'envers du décor comme
moi j'ai plaisir à venir ici en termes
et vous c'est important de se connaître
pour savoir que la mécanique elle et
elle est pas si différente en fait
le but de l auteur des violences et de
ne pas perdre sa proie donc pour la
garder il va faire de magnifiques
promesses et donc vous en tant que futur
avocat pendant les périodes où vous êtes
en suivi de cette victime pour monter un
dossier peut-être que vous commencez à
sentir que d'être en train de la perdre
parce qu'elle hésite elle doute elles se
disent j'ai peut-être envie de voila
c'est peut-être finalement un peu de ma
faute et c'est pour ça qu'on a des
vicitmes qui retirent leur plainte et
vous vous pourriez vous dire elle m'a
lâché je vais quand même pas retenter de
travailler avec elle alors que j'ai
perdu 15 jours de travail pour rien
parce qu'au dernier moment la changer
d'avis sauf que elle n'a pas changé
d'avis volontairement à la changer
d'avis parce qu'elle était dans ce cycle
des violences et c'est important que
vous ayez bien ça en tête en tant que
future profession pourrait se dire qu'on
apporte une expertise aux victimes qu'on
accompagne et puis voilà c'est notre
savoir faire sauf que notre objectif
c'est pas d'avoir des victimes qui s'en
sortent et de se dire tant pis pour les
autres on se dit que plus il va y avoir
la prévention la sensibilisation des
plus jeunes âges des les écoles plus on
va éradiquer en tout cas tenter
d'éradiquer le problème
[Musique]
là des nuits blanches elle fait des
cauchemars
il n'y a pas de violence physique mais
il ya quand même eu des menaces des
menaces de mort sur elle et les enfants
il va aussi utiliser les enfants pour
nuire à madame amon dire à son fils de 4
ans que sa mère est méchante qu'elle va
dans des voitures pour tromper son père
et ça fait deux ans qu'elle dort du coup
dans la chambre avec ses enfants elle
était inquiète parce qu'elle dit oui
mais si monsieur rentre je vais pas
l'entendre donc je lui dis peut-être de
trouver des solutions de mettre une
chaise derrière la porte la solution qui
a aussi des répercussions comme tu dis
que tu conseilles de bloquer avec une
chaise c'est rajouter un élément ouvrir
une petite pause place question quoi
enfin en tant qu'enfant je ne pense pas
que tu sort indemne
ne pensons pas que les enfants sont
épargnés l'enfant il est tout le temps
témoigne d'ailleurs pour nous parle plus
d'enfants t - on parle d'enfants
victimes même s'ils ne sont pas des
victimes directes de violences exercées
sur eux ce sont les victimes
aujourd'hui les enfants sont aussi
accueillis au sein de notre association
je trouve que c'est capital parce que la
violence elle commence dans l'enfance il
n'y a pas une seule personne violente
qui n'a pas vécu des violences pendant
son enfance ça va mon grand
oui tu as une petite voix
ouais je sais mon grand jeu je viens là
dessus c'est de rappeler maman rappeler
un peu tout le monde pour avoir de tes
nouvelles ces enfants en fait pour moi
c'est juste une continuité de notre
travail quand on se pose la question
aujourd'hui on dit mais comment on
pourrait faire cesser ces violences je
pense que c'est déjà prendre le mal à la
racine en les prenant en charge le plus
tôt possible
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est pas comment faire et bien non
c'est pas bon jour
venu et là derrière ben ya pierre bah
oui à pierre
sarah bas super petits soins ben c'est
normal mais journal que tu as déjà vu
mélissa qui est sa sagesse ouais une
petite maman qui dépose son enfant pour
vous savez qui c'est parce qu'elle est
masquée mais je les ai connus celui du
bordelais bien
connu je sais pas comment puis je me
taisais tout mais j'ai un regard de
braise c'est ça je suis tombé sous votre
charge et les yeux revolver
ça c'est une petite stagiaire enfin
partiellement upi la habana et
commandeur capitaine que le même sort
ça va nickel depuis la dernière fois
c'est à quévert l'atelier 14h30 ah oui
et cédric arrive 13h30 et à combien
d'enfants aujourd'hui le set et il ya
des enfants de tous âges oui je dois y
sont plus entre 8 et 9 conagra et c'est
très gentil de bénévoles dans l'histoire
ouais ouais c'est lui qui a fait la
démarche qu'a proposé le projet les
profs je marque on est un peu dans l art
thérapeute années et il travaille à
l'école de design
c'est pour moi ça c'est pour les vieux
on va dire ça
on s'assoit tous comme moi si vous
pouvez
et vous mettez vos mains soit soit sur
vous nous avez entre vos jambes droites
comme vous comme vous sentez bien
d'accord mais on essaie de fermer les
yeux de garder les yeux fermés
et on fait simplement que respirait
juste ça
et on peut rouvrir les yeux
ça va
ils pourront
donc fait comme la dernière fois
merci
maintenant je vous invite à découvrir au
dispositif que je vous ai mis à
disposition
et à explorer son contenu
[Musique]
m
et maintenant vous avez découvert à
l'intérieur
je vous invite à imaginer une histoire
pour vous si vous aviez un super pouvoir
si vous étiez un super héros
[Musique]
non
avant
moi j'ai fait
là est fait pour ça pour être voulu la
partager
ça permet à tout le monde au même niveau
on oublie tout on parle pas du tout
violence ici on est tous là avec deux
bouts de ficelle finalement et on
revient des choses simples qui vous
entre dans l'instant est dans une forme
de réalité
[Musique]
eh ben je vous propose de
mettre votre exploration et votre
histoire en pause et je vais passer
récupérer tous les petits éléments
je pense que ça permet aux enfants
d'être avec eux mêmes tout en étant avec
les autres enfin vrai c'est un peu
particulier mais on n'est pas en train
de comment dire de ressasser des choses
on est en train de s'évader mais avec
l'or le regard bienveillant du groupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
l'association au fil des années j'ai
l'impression que l embrasse tellement
tous les effets collatéraux des
violences faites aux femmes que ça va
finir par être une association d'intérêt
général où on va finalement on peut
imaginer que ça pourrait aller encore
plus loin parce qu'on se rend compte
quand on s'y intéresse un petit peu que
les violences faites aux femmes c'est
pas un truc qui touche une personne et
puis on en parle plus long ce soit non
séparés c'est fini ça impacte toute la
famille mais quand j'ai toute la famille
c'est les enfants mais aussi le cadre
professionnel la famille ça peut être
les grands parents aussi 20 mois pour
avoir vécu de près ou de loin des
situations comme ça on voit bien que ces
impacts une dizaine de personnes
finalement autour de la victime donc
donc quand je vois l'association grandir
comme ça c'est à l'image je dirais de de
ce que font les violences sur les femmes
ça n'impacte pas que la femme victime
c'est un pack toute la société
[Musique]
on a envie que ce que ce modèle existe
partout sur le territoire pour venir en
aide aux victimes maintenant qu'on sait
tous et toutes que ça ça a lieu partout
et dans tous les milieux c'est
malheureusement quand nécessaire
jusqu'au jour où il n'aura plus besoin
mais pas demain ça
[Musique]
non